♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, THE MASSACRE
IN PARKLAND, FLORIDA, HAS NOT
SUPPOSEDLY SPARKED A NEW PUSH ON
THE LEFT TO TAKE GUNS AWAY FROM
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
IN THE NEW CALL IS FOR A BAN ON
SO-CALLED ASSAULT RIFLES, A AND
PRECISE TERM THAT INCLUDES
AR-15s.
FANS OF ANY TYPE ARE NOT
POPULAR, BUT MANY ARE UPSET THAT
IF IT PROMISED TO SAVE LIVES?
WOULD AN ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN AND
PREVENT FUTURE SHOOTINGS?
THAT IS THE KEY QUESTION.
LUCKILY WE DO NOT NEED TO GUESS
ON THE ANSWER.
WE ALREADY HAD AN ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN FOR TEN YEARS
STARTING IN 1994.
THAT LAW WHEN IT WAS WRITTEN
MANDATED A COMPREHENSIVE STUDY
OF THE EFFECTIVENESS WHICH WAS
PRODUCED.
SO WE HAVE A DEFINITIVE ANSWER.
ACCORDING TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, THE ASSAULT WEAPONS
BAN PASSED IN 1994 HAD NO EFFECT
ON CRIME RATES.
NONE, NOBODY WAS SAVED BY IT.
THAT SHOULD NOT BE SURPRISING IF
YOU KNOW THE NUMBERS, BECAUSE
DESPITE THE HYPE, RIFLES ARE NOT
THE WEAPON OF CHOICE FOR THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF KILLERS
IN AMERICA.
IN 2015, THE MOST RECENT YEAR
WHICH WE HAVE DATA, RIFLES WERE
USED IN A TOTAL OF 252 HOMICIDES
IN AMERICA.
BY COMPARISON, OLD-FASHIONED
KNIVES, SHARPENED METAL WAS USED
IN 1500 KILLINGS, BLUNT OBJECTS
KILLED 437.
624 MURDERS WERE COMMITTED WITH
BARE HANDS AND FEET.
THE ACTUAL NUMBERS ON THAT FROM
THE GOVERNMENT.
THE SCIENCES AND ON THIS AS
CONCLUSIVE, AND THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO TELL YOU THAT THEY STILL
BELIEVE IN SCIENCE AND YOU DON'T
DO NOT CARE ABOUT THE
SCIENCE.
THEY ARE STILL TRYING TO BAN
AR-15s.
TO THE NEW LEGISLATION IN THE
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN OF 2017,
PRODUCED BY SEVERAL DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS WOULD OUTLAW THE
MANUFACTURE, THE SALE, THE
TRANSFER OF MORE THAN 200
"MILITARY STYLE ASSAULT
WEAPONS."
WHAT IS A MILITARY STYLE ASSAULT
WEAPON?
ANYONE THAT HAS FEATURES LIKE A
DETACHABLE MAGAZINE, A PISTOL
GRIP, A FORWARD GRIP, A FOLDING
STOCK OR THE BURIAL SHROUD,
PRESUMABLY MADE BECAUSE OF ITS
PURPOSE IS SHROUDED IN MYSTERY
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT PROPOSE
BANNING IT.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT IS.
MOST ARE COSMETIC FEATURES, THEY
DO IN MOUNT MAKE THEM MORE
DEADLY, THEY MAKE THEM LOOK MORE
SCARY.
AND THAT IS ENOUGH.
NONE OF THIS NONSENSE WOULD
LIMIT MASS KILLINGS.
THE PEOPLE PUSHING A DO NOT
BELIEVE IT WOULD HAVE THAT
EFFECT.
THEY WILL ADMIT THAT, BECAUSE IT
IS IMPOSSIBLE TO DENY IT.
THE NUMBERS ARE IN.
THE REAL PROBLEM IS THEY HAVE IS
LOATHING THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
LIKE THE FIRST AMENDMENT THEY NO
LONGER BELIEVE IN.
THEY THINK THAT YOU DO NOT HAVE
A RIGHT TO OWN A GUN AND WORKING
HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CANNOT OWN A GUN.
IT IS NOT ABOUT SAFETY, IT IS
CONTROL.
HERE NEW YORK CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER, RUNNING FOR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR, JOINING US TONIGHT.
COUNSEL WILLIAMS, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
>> IT IS GOOD TIME TO TALK ABOUT
GUN SAFETY.
>> Tucker: IT IS A GOOD TIME
TO TALK ABOUT GUN SAFETY.
I THINK IT IS ALWAYS A GOOD
TIME.
WE HAD AN ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN
MUCH LIKE THE ONES THAT
DEMOCRATS AND THE SENATE ARE
PROPOSING.
WE HAD IT FOR TEN YEARS, AND WE
KNOW, BECAUSE IT WAS STUDIED
EXHAUSTIVELY THAT IT SAVED NO
LIVES.
WHAT IS THE MOTIVE AND
RE-IMPOSING THE LAW?
>> I NOTICED ON YOUR DATA COMING
HE DID NOT PUT THAT 90,000
AMERICANS ARE SHOT, 30,000
KILLED BY GUNS EVERY SINGLE YEAR
KILLED BY GUNS EVERY SINGLE YEA
YEAR.
--
>> WHICH PERCENT ARE SUICIDES?
>> PEOPLE ARE ACTING LIKE THAT
MATTERS.
>> Tucker: IT DOES MATTER, THE
MAJORITY ARE SUICIDES.
>> THAT WOULD MEAN THAT 10,000
ARE MURDERED.
AND TWO WHICH IS CRITICAL AND
IMPORTANT.
THE PRESENCE OF THE GUN
INCREASES A SUCCESSFUL SUICIDE
PERCENTAGE.
SO THAT IS IMPORTANT.
>> Tucker: SUICIDE SIDE NOTE,
YOU ARE SUDDENLY AGAINST SUICIDE
WHEN IT IS COMMITTED BY A GUN?
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ALL CLEAR, YOUR MASSIVE
INFLATION IS ALL GOOD.
>> Tucker: YOU CANNOT TO NOTE
THAT TWO-THIRDS OF THE DEATHS
WERE SELF-INFLICTED.
I'M NOT FOR SUICIDE, BUT I'M
SURE THAT YOU ARE, BUT I WANT TO
BE CLEAR WITH OUR VIEWERS --
>> I WANT TO BE CLEAR AND SAY
THAT THE LIVES OF SUICIDE ALSO
MATTER AND THE 10,000 MURDERS
SHOULD BE COUNTED AS WELL.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT FOR A GUN
AND KILLING OF ANY KIND, MY ONLY
POINT IS THAT LEGISLATORS MAKE
LAWS AND THEY DO SO IN THE HOPE
THAT THEY WILL HAVE THE INTENDED
EFFECT.
AND WE KNOW FROM TEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE THAT AN ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN DOES NOT WORK.
THERE IS NO DEBATE, THE DOJ CAME
TO THE CONCLUSION AFTER STUDYING
IT.
WHY WOULD WE WANT IT AGAIN?
>> THE REAL QUESTION IS AND IT
IS TO YOU, TUCKER.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
NOT HAVE UNSCENTED ACCESS TO
GUNS IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> Tucker: I DO NOT KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS, UNCOVER LAWMAKERS
WHO ARE TRYING TO IMPOSE LAWS ON
THE REST OF US AND I TRY TO
ASSESS WHETHER THOSE LAWS ARE
EFFECTIVE.
>> IF WE ARE BOTH BEING
HONEST --
>> Tucker: I AM BEING HONEST.
>> WE HAVE TO START IT A POINT
WHERE PEOPLE AGREE.
SHOULD WE HAVE UNVENTED ACCESS
TO GUNS IN THE COUNTRY?
>> I DO NOT KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS, WE DO NOT HAVE UNFETTERED
ACCESS.
THAT IS VISCERALLY OVERSTATED.
>> THAT IS THE QUESTION THAT I'M
TRYING TO GET TO YOU SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT TO DO AFTER WE HAVE AGREED
WITH THAT.
>> Tucker: RATHER TO GET INTO
THIS SCARY WORLD --
>> IT IS NOT SCARY.
>> Tucker: THOSE WORDS DO NOT
MEAN MUCH.
LET'S GET INTO THE SPECIFICS OF
THE LEGISLATION THAT TO THE
LEFT, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
PUSHING NOW.
GUNS THAT HAVE A BURIAL SHROUD
OUGHT TO BE PROHIBITED,
OUTLAWED, BANNED.
MY QUESTION IS WIDE?
WHY WOULD THE BARREL SHROUD TO
MAKE THE GUN MORE DANGEROUS?
>> THAT IS THE WRONG QUESTION.
>> Tucker: THIS IS THE
QUESTION THAT IS HERE.
>> AND IT WORKS, BECAUSE YOU ARE
GIVING PEOPLE THE RESUME --
>> Tucker: IT IS NOT
RESPONDING TO ME, I'M RESPONDING
TO A PIECE OF PROPOSED
LEGISLATION PROPOSED BY YOUR
ALLIES IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, AND I'M ASKING YOU ABOUT
THE DETAILS OF THE LEGISLATION
PRETTY WERE PROPOSE BANNING GUNS
THAT HAD PISTOL GRIPS AND BARREL
SHROUD'S AND BAYONETS GLOVES.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> WHAT YOU DO WELL IS FOCUSED
ON SOMETHING.
>> Tucker: FOCUSING ON FACTS.
>> I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE REAL
QUESTION THAT YOU REFUSE TO
ANSWER, WHETHER OR NOT THIS
COUNTRY SHOULD HAVE ON FETID
ACCESS TO GUNS.
>> Tucker: THE ANSWER IS NO,
WE DO NOT ALLOW A 9-YEAR-OLD'S
GUNS.
>> THAT IS THE ANSWER.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT SHOULD WE
DO, BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
SOMETHING LIKE A CAR THAT WAS
MADE JUST TO TRANSPORT PEOPLE
AND ACCIDENTALLY KILLS PEOPLE,
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
REGULATION.
YOU NEED INSURANCE, YOU HAVE TO
HAVE TRAINING.
>> Tucker: CARS ARE NOT
TREMENDOUSLY REGULATED.
>> A GUN THAT IS MADE TO KILL
PEOPLE, YOU HAVE TO HAVE
TRAINING TO PURCHASE A GUN IN
>> Tucker: ARE YOU GOING TO
ADDRESS THE ACTUAL LAW PROPOSED
BY ACTUAL DEMOCRATS IN THE
ACTUAL U.S. SENATE OR NO?
>> THE COUNTRY THAT HAS 50% OF
ALL CIVILIAN GUNS IN THE WORLD
AND 4% OF THE POPULATION, ARE
YOU WILLING TO ADMIT THAT THAT
HAS SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE GUN
VIOLENCE IN THE COUNTRY?
>> Tucker: I AM DEALING IN THE
REALM OF SOCIAL SCIENCE AND
FACTS.
HERE'S WHAT WE DO AGREE ON.
I WANT TO START -- WE ARE BOTH
RESPONDING FROM SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS, BUT THE FACT THAT YOU
ARE UNWILLING TO ADDRESS THE SPE
ARE UNWILLING TO ADDRESS THE SPI
ARE UNWILLING TO ADDRESS THE SPS
ARE UNWILLING TO ADDRESS THE SPO
ARE UNWILLING TO ADDRESS THE SP
ARE UNWILLING TO ADDRESS THE SPH
ARE UNWILLING TO ADDRESS THE SPE
LEGISLATION SUGGESTS TO ME THAT
YOUR REAL NAME IS NOT REDUCING
GUN VIOLENCE, BUT SOMETHING, I
WOULD SAY, HIT IN.
>> NOT AT ALL.
>> Tucker: THAT IS PROBABLY
YOUR AIM.
>> I'M RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR,
BECAUSE IN NEW YORK CITY, I HAVE
BEEN A LEADING VOICE AMONG
OTHERS REDUCING GUN VIOLENCE BY
22%.
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE TO REDUCE GUN
VIOLENCE IN THE COUNTRY?
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.
>> EXACTLY MY POINT.
AND YOU HAVE A PURGE, YOU SHOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE.
YOU NEED TO BE RESPONSIBLE --
>> Tucker: I AM RESPONSIBLE,
BECAUSE I DEAL IN FACTS, WHILE
YOU DEAL IN MINDLESS
GENERALIZATIONS.
>> PEOPLE SHOULD NOT HAVE
UNFRIENDED ACCESS TO GUNS IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW WHO
GAVE YOU THE TALKING POINTS, BUT
YOU SHOULD FIRE HIM.
>> THERE WILL BE PEOPLE THAT
ALWAYS RESPOND TO ME AND I AM
HAPPY BECAUSE I CAME ON THE
SHOW.
>> Tucker: YOU OUGHT TO GET
OFF OF TWITTER AND DO SOMETHING
FOR THE STATE OF NEW YORK.
YOU HAVE TOO MUCH FREE TIME, GET
OFF OF TWITTER!
>> I TOLD YOU WHAT I DID.